figaro l'oeil bonjour nous sommes en
direct ce mercredi matin pour vous
parler de la guerre en ukraine pour
faire un point de situation est avec moi
bien sûr alexis faire chaque bonjour
alexis
journalistes et adjoint au pôle actu du
figaro tout au long de ce live bien sûr
vous n'hésitez pas à nous poser vos
questions on essaiera d'y répondre au
mieux comme d'habitude on va un peu
faire un point sur la sur la situation
donc surtout vous n'hésitez pas on va
commencer peut-être avec cette carte
alexis cette carte un peu général et qui
montre que c'est dans le bon parce que
maintenant tout se joue dans cette
guerre est ce que la russie est en train
de prendre l'avantagé dans cette guerre
en fait c'est la grande bataille
décisive depuis l'acte 2 de la guerre on
va dire à partir du mois d'avril très
rapidement les russes ont quitté le nord
du pays la situation s'est stabilisée
dans le sud et tout se joue désormais
dans l'est le nomma c'est vraiment la
région la plus orientale de l'ukraine
qui composait de deux régions qui fait
lougansk et donnait ce qu est en fait
les russes avancent depuis trois
semaines le rythme de l'avancé russe
s'est accélérée et là ils ont conquis
successivement deux villes les échéances
et c'est vers donesk est donc patent il
contrôler l'intégralité de lougansk donc
entre guillemets ils ont fait la moitié
du chemin pour pouvoir annoncer une
bataille décisive dans le donbass ils
ont pris longue ans maintenant on va
voir que ce qui reste à faire pour les
russes leur objectif pour pouvoir
annoncer une première victoire politique
c'est de prendre le restant du dos nièce
de l'oblast de données alors pour bien
montrer sur la carte le blue power
blacks ce dont parlait de lougansk il
est ici c'est celui qui participe
seulement qu'il va jusqu'à ici est celui
de donetsk c'est celui qui est sur cette
ligne là et qui redescend ici dont il ya
encore pas mal de territoire il ya
encore pas mal de temps il faut avoir
des ordres de grandeur en tête le le
dombass au total ces cinquante mille
kilomètres carrés c'est
c'est assez grand c'est pas loin du
benelux et
et donc là si vous voulez les deux
oblath sont chacun à peu près 25 mille
kilomètres carrés ils ont maintenant
l'intégralité de lougansk il leur manque
la moitié de dounia czc est en fait ce
qui est important mais là on veut faire
la somme est davantage c'est qu'il ya
des villes symboliques maintenant il ya
deux nouvelles villes ccra matt horth
heslault viance qui sont les nouveaux
objectifs dans l'est dans les semaines à
venir de la russie maintenant la
question ça va être le rythme de
l'avancé russe après la percée de ces
deux trois dernières semaines et ce
qu'ils vont pouvoir continuer et ça
c'est en grande partie une donnée
inconnue alors on est une question
d'abord de florian richard qui valent
pas les ordres qu'il veut nous qui veut
nous faire parler d'un autre endroit
alors mal juste en parler peut être
rapidement qui nous dit est ce qu'on
peut s'attendre à une attaque sur le
pont de crimée alors le pont de crime et
la crime et je pense que ce dont il
parle c'est peux descendre un peu plus
au sud donc on parlait de ces deux au
blast qui sont ici et je lui ai alors je
sais pas si on peut le voir sur la carte
vous a fait voilà c'est c'est là vous
voyez crime et il y à un pont qui relie
la crimée à la russie alors c'est le
pont du détroit de kertch que les russes
ont fabriqué très rapidement en quelques
années parce que simplement la crimée
qu'ils avaient annexé en 2014 était
séparé du reste du territoire russe donc
il fallait construire un pont pour
relier la russie et la crimée et on en
parlera tout tout à l'heure mais mais
mais il ya une
menaces ukrainienne navale qui persiste
alors même que les russes théoriquement
on détruit la flotte
ukrainienne et donc ils ont peur que les
que les quelques les ukrainiens arrive à
détruire ce pont et doit aider donc que
couple à la crim et même si aujourd'hui
on voit bien que l'objectif stratégique
russe qui consistait justement à relier
la crimée par la terre
jusqu'au nom bassil et remplit donc
c'est plus le même le même objectif mais
malgré tout s'il était privé de ce pont
ça serait une défaite pour les russes
est assez anecdotique mais ils ont
déployé donc autour du autour du pont
des dauphins alors ça il ya toute une
littérature à propos du rôle des animaux
marins dans la dans la dans la guerre
des mines de en termes de surveillance
et ccd des dauphins qui sont entraînés
par l'homme donc voilà on en a beaucoup
aussi dans la dans la base du nord en
arctique mais là on l'est on les voit
dans la flotte de la mer noire ont les
avions en syrie également hélas ils sont
vraiment autour du pont de de cris mais
bon on peut imaginer qu'ils ont qu'ils
aient peur d'un minaj du ton que sièges
et donc ils surveillent le fait qu'ils
aient pas des nageurs de combat ils font
ça avec des dauphins avec des dauphins
alors il ya pas que ça ya aussi un tout
un tas de deux radars parce qu'ils
craignent notamment une menace de
missiles ukrainien puisque on reparlera
mais mais les les les ukrainiens
aujourd'hui une capacité de frappe en
profondeur
on va dire quasiment à l'échelle de
sébastopol quelques et le port c'est en
bas tout en bas de cette caramba alors
je pense pas d'ailleurs que les
ukrainiens et la capacité
théoriquement ils n'ont pas d'aller
d'aller jusqu'au pont de crime et qui
est plus à l'est mais malgré tout on a
vu le dispositif défensive russe s'est
solidifiée autour de ce pont donc c'est
bien qu'ils ne pouvaient ils le vivent
comme une menace et il ya un enjeu on a
à charge eakin dix questions
mathématiques ou une estimation du
territoire ukrainien perdu en ce moment
mais je
gérais imprimer les chiffres ils sont
pas complètement à jour il faut rajouter
probablement peut-être 5% depuis
depuis justement ces dernières victoires
locales dans dans le blast 2 le de
lougansk mai mais grosso modo donc
l'ukraine ses 600 mille kilomètres
carrés c'est plus grand que la france
ses 55 cent quarante mille la france
donc c'est vraiment un grand pays et
aujourd'hui la russie contrôlent plus de
20% on vit entre 20 et 25 % de la
totalité sachant qu'ils ont pris une
partie
en 2014 la crimée et une partie du
dombass qui est elle cette partie
hachuré et ensuite si vous voulez il ya
eu nonna milia les territoires au nord
qu'ils ont conquis voilà jusqu'à kharkiv
exclu et puis à toute cette bande de
territoire au sud qui va de la crimée
jusque dans base donc aujourd'hui c'est
120 mille kilomètres carrés 20%
de l'ukraine et pour donner un ordre
d'idée la grèce c'est 130 mille
kilomètres carrés donc en réalité on est
quasiment c'est quasiment la taille de
la grèce donc voilà ça donne une
certaine idée
des territoires conquis et je prenais un
autre et je regardais les villes il ya
44 villes de plus de 5000 habitants
en ukraine et aujourd'hui les russes en
contrôle 14 sachant que ce qui est
intéressant c'est que sur ses quatorze y
en a que six qui ont voté contre qui ont
été prises depuis le 24 février les
autres avaient été pris avant c'était
des villes et rool de crimée où la vie
de john yates ou la ville de lougansk
très bien dans tout l ume un peu pour
voir un peu ce qui passe donc voilà vous
avez ici le blast de donetsk dont nous
devons parler on va zoom et un peu à la
frontière je vous proposer cette
nouvelle carte pour qu'on comprenne un
peu mieux mais voilà je voulais vous le
dire pour comprendre un peu où est-ce
qu'on était sur cette carte voilà donc
là on a 12 mai à l'endroit alors à des
conflits on voit du coup severodonezk
leach ans qui sont assez vite à l'est
qui sont toutes allées et qui sont ces
villes qui ont un peu ces derniers ces
dernières semaines concentré l'attention
absolument en fait les échéances qui
essaient verdonnais c'était les deux
dernières vie 2 le blast de lougansk qui
manquait à la russie donc c'était le
premier objectif et on voit que la
manoeuvre russe si vous voulez help llc
une sorte de te nice tu peux un tout
petit peu de décence voilà là on imagine
à peu près mais c'est une sorte de
tenaille avec une pince au nord est et
une pince aussi il faut imaginer qu'elle
qu'elle continue le soleil est en fête
au nord la ligne de front correspond peu
ou prou à une rivière qui s'appelle le
dos nièce et donc les russes avaient
avaient franchement du mal à franchir
cette rivière donc le front du nord
entre guillemets n'a pas tellement
évolué ces dernières semaines et donc
toute l'offensive russe est passé par le
sud est en fait ce qui est les
territoires halal est aujourd'hui sont
contrôlés par les russes mais elle à
l'origine il n'était pas la ligne de
front grosso modo s'arrêter à ces
vernonnaise et les russes ont fait une
manoeuvre on va dire d'enveloppement
pour en remontant vers le nord via pop à
snacks a été un des moments clés de de
la bataille du dombass et ensuite ils
sont remontés ils ont coincé en fait les
ukrainiens dans une sorte de chaudron où
il y avait ces verdonnais scalisi chance
alors c'est vernonnaise qui est tombé en
premier
surtout que la ville était à l'est de la
rivière donc c'était difficile pour les
ukrainiens de la ravitailler et puis
ensuite les russes se sont compris ce
week-end ils ont pris les îles chance
que et les à l'aller les ukrainiens ont
réussi à ceux à se replier sap a été
comme comme marioupol qui a été
complètement encerclé puis les les
forces chrétiennes qui était à marioupol
à soi elles ont été capturées soit tu es
tu sais il ya très peu de force qu'ont
pu
s'échapper se replier à partir du moment
où les russes en cercle et là il ya eu
une méthode de
repli ukrainienne mais malgré tout on
sait pas exactement mais ils ont
probablement perdu des milliers de
combattants et surtout beaucoup de
matériel plus ou moins légers plus ou
moins lourd mais en tout cas souvent on
a vu qu'ils quittaient
cboe orientale du nom bassil le quitter
soit à pied soit sur des petites
voitures civiles donc ils n'ont pas pu
emporter les les les pièces d'artillerie
les véhicules blindés et c'est donc là
c'est une victoire à la fois tactique
pour les russes c'est une victoire
malgré tout stratégique parce que c'est
c'est encore c'était un des deux
objectifs de la grande bataille du
donbass et puis c'est un objectif une
victoire politique une première victoire
politique puisque le blast de lougansk
aujourd'hui entièrement contrôlée par la
séparatiste de la république populaire
de lougansk qui peuvent dire voilà on a
on a obtenu ce résultat et on peut
d'ailleurs imaginer maintenant que le
blast est réuni dans son ensemble on
peut imaginer un référendum de
rattachement à la russie ce modèle de ce
qui avait été fait en crimée par exemple
absolument alors le kremlin s'est pas
encore prononcé officiellement de scie
mais on voit que c'est un thème qui
monte depuis des semaines il ya le blast
de séparatistes de lougansk qui le
demandent ceux de deux nièces qu mais
aussi les territoires plus récemment
conquis par la russie notamment au sud
de l'ukraine à carson à zaporijia etc
alors on a justement des questions de la
salle hakim dit cette guerre va durer
longtemps je pense on se rappelle au
début de cette guerre la russie avait
pris énormément de territoire avancé
assez rapidement sauf dans le dans le
donbass et on va y revenir au t2 ça
c'était très intéressant cette guerre
contre certains personnes portent ce
prêt pensé que ça pouvait aller très
vite finalement elle à prendre des mois
voire des années elle va prendre en tout
cas des mois des années il ya trop de
variables
on peut pas mais mais c'est une
possibilité c'est un des scénarios
possibles mais en tout cas elle va
encore très probablement prendre des
mois on se rend bien compte de l'échelle
des combats là on est soixante deux
rectangles
globalement univar 150 km de long et un
peu moins de 100 km de hauteur c'est
l'échelle des combats est relativement
petit surtout par rapport à la taille de
l'ukraine or on peut imaginer
effectivement une reprise de l'ensemble
du nom basse par les rues ce n'est pas
une certitude on peut l'imaginer on va
dire probablement d'ici la fin du mois
d'août c'est quelque chose
d'envisageable encore une fois ça n'est
qu'un scénario mais c'est envisageable
mais après est-ce qu'on s'arrêtera là
est ce que les russes vont vouloir
pousser soi underdark kharkiv soit vers
l'ouest et inversement on parle beaucoup
aujourd'hui de l'hypothèse d'une
offensive d'été ukrainienne qui est
serré justement d' d'avancé de vers le
sud de l'ukraine pour tourner pour
menacer là l'acrimed donc donc oui on
parle moi ça fait quasiment une
certitude sauf s'il y avait une sorte de
point des kids in militaire que les deux
belligérants étaient épuisés et puis on
serait obligé de négocier mais on en
n'est a priori pas là ce moment là mais
parce que ça bouge razida nous dit
quelque chose d'assez intéressant
justement le problème des russes
n'étaient pas de franchir la rivière
mais les bunkers et défense consolidé
depuis huit ans dans les villes ça y est
allé de ses unes c'est intéressant comme
réflexion c'est à dire qu'en fait vous
avez dit tout à l'heure qu'au départ de
la base donc le 24 février les russes
n'ont pas avancé frontalement dans le
nom basse ils l'ont contourner en fait
plutôt par le par le nord on va dire
entre kharkiv est et voilà et mais
pourquoi parce que par exemple parce que
voilà pour le coup on voit bien en fait
les territoires qui ont été pris par la
russie dès le 24 février si les
territoires orange en revanche en phase
de dounia sq les russes n'ont jamais
avancé depuis le 24 février pourquoi
parce que c'était à cet endroit là que
les effectivement les ukrainiens avaient
construit une sorte de ligne maginot
avec des bunkers et c est leur ligne de
défense était extrêmement solide et
c'est pour ça que les
son suivi cette manoeuvre de tenaille
non je parle est là on la voit très bien
la manoeuvre de taylor sauf que cette
taille à très grande échelle ils n'ont
pas les moyens à réaliser donc plutôt
que de faire sept grandes manoeuvres de
tonalité ils ont fait une taille de plus
en plus petit et qui aujourd'hui
s'est réduite à la prise de deux villes
et donc voilà mais c'est pour ça qu'ils
n'ont pas
enfin attaquer frontalement cette ligne
de défense ukrainienne est aujourd'hui
cette ligne de défense ukrainienne
principal est bien réelle elle est
tombée les ukrainiens se sont repliés on
va voir sur deux autres lignes et on ne
sait pas actuellement qu'elle est là
qu'elle est la solidité de ces deux
lignes ukrainienne et donc ça et on ne
connaît pas non plus l'état de l'armée
russe après cette offensive le l'édition
donc qu'est-ce qu'elle a les moyens de 2
to de continuer sur sa lancée ça c'est
aujourd'hui c'est une inconnue on voit
que là ça avance un peu mais vous voyez
là c'est la carte la plus mais les deux
objectifs principaux et les deux villes
de ce l'audience quelques rames à tort
ce qu'ils sont deux autres villes de
plus de 5000 habitants et crds amateurs
ce qu'est la capitale régionale de le
blaze de deux nièces depuis que la ville
de deux nièces qu en 2014 a été prise
par les séparatistes donc là c'est
l'objectif stratégique russe pour la
bataille du dombass et entre les deux
vous voyez qu'il ya deux petits points
un peu un peu plus petit il ya six
verres sq et bach mouthe ça c'est la
nouvelle première ligne de défense
ukrainienne mais dont on ne sait pas si
elle va pouvoir tenir très longtemps
sylvère c'est pas une grande ville il ya
je crois que c'était 12000 habitants
avant la guerre bat commune c'est un peu
plus grand c'est soixante dix mille
habitants mais malgré tout
les ouvriers les russes sont proches là
ils sont à dix kilomètres de 6 vers ce
qu'à 10 kilomètres de bach mouthe et en
fait le front du nord russe par ailleurs
s'approche quand même
de ce l'audience qui sont à aller entre
10 et 20 km donc c'est très peu 10 et 20
km de manière concrète se dire que c'est
à portée de l'artillerie et ça c'était
donc ça c'est évidemment ça c'est très
important sur le sur le terrain puisque
la bataille du noma c'est d'abord une
bataille d'artillerie je sais pas si
vous vous souvenez mais dans l'est dans
le premier mois de la guerre en ukraine
ce qu'on voyait principalement dans les
photos de presse c'était des chartreuses
des blindés russes qui avançait en
pologne en colonne soleil sur les routes
ce qui d'ailleurs faisait bondir pas mal
d'expérience terre qui disait mais quand
on fait une guerre on n'avance pas en
colloque comme ça sur la com sur la
place rouge tout cas ça c'était le
les images de l'acte 1 de la guerre dans
le donbass c'est pas du tout ça c'est
des duels d'artillerie donc des duels
des duels d'artillerie ont tirs à 10 20
30 km souvent on voit pas l'ennemi a à
l'oeil nu on tire l'ennemi réplique
c'est ce qu'on appelle des tirs de
contre batterie c'est quand on essaye de
taper les l'artillerie ennemie qui vient
de tirer
et donc c'est une bataille qui avancent
lentement serre que les russes ont un
avantage quantitatif que le sale en
termes de puissance de feu on parle de
jusqu'à 100 milles au but par par jour
c'est un chiffre qui est donnée par
colonel michel goya c'est considérable
et donc là en face les ukrainiens ont
probablement dix fois moins de puissance
de feu on verra qu'ils ont peut-être
d'autres avantages et donc les russes
avancent comme ça c'est qu'ils gèlent le
terrain avec leur artillerie et ensuite
dans un deuxième temps il envoie
à la fois les chars et l'infanterie pour
contrôler le terrain mais c'est ça la
bataille du no mas aujourd'hui c'est un
deuil darty gré à gré des chalets et on
peut aussi rappeler à quoi ressemble
maintenant les vies de sellers et des
sites chance c'était villes qui sont
alors c'est pas marioupol non plus mais
ce sont des villes qui sont très
largement détruite ce qui est
intéressant c'est qu'ils aient une
grande partie de la population de ces
villes qui sont partis qui sont partis
soit vers l'ouest du côté ukrainien soit
vers l'est du côté russe ou ou pro russe
et ce qui a été bien montré dans des
reportages notamment sur france 2 c'est
que les habitants qui sont restés par
exemple à l'isie chance qu à sévir
donesk c'est généralement des habitants
pro-russe donc en fait les soldats
russes ont été plutôt pour le coup
accueillie plutôt assez bien par les
habitants mais me diallo le fait que les
habitants qui restent dans ces villes
c'est pas tout la ville d'avant la
guerre on arrose anna qui nous parle de
la chute de nos épaules qui a pu être un
déclencheur de cette de cette offensive
il ya aussi ça le déclencheur c'est déjà
un premier aboutissement jeudi en fait
le fait que des forces finissent une
opération permet de les redéployer et
c'est peut-être ça qui a joué aussi oui
absolument mais et d'ailleurs c'est là
qu'on voit que la russie aujourd'hui ne
sait réellement avancer que sur un front
c'est à dire qu'en réalité pour pouvoir
me et là je ne parle même pas de dire
qu'avant il ferait le dombass et en même
temps le sud de l'ukraine
le nord-est fait ça même à l'intérieur
de la bataille du dombass on voit qu'ils
ont pu pour avancer depuis l'est et
depuis l'issue dans cette manoeuvre de
tonight puis ce but un peu mettre en
suspens leurs leur offensif du nord vers
saint viance quelques avait trois
semaines avant un peu un peu avancé donc
m
visiblement aujourd'hui n'ont pas les
moyens de mener plusieurs offensives
de deux fronts et ça c'est aussi ça dit
quelque chose probablement des capacités
oui oui parce qu'on rappelle regardant
cette carte au départ on avait les
russes qui étaient passés par il avait
essayé de passer par kiev par soumis
kharkiv ah oui l'europe qui avait poussé
par le sud on était sur une attaque un
peu gêné a quasiment générale de tout le
pays à part l'ouest parce qu'il n'y a
pas de frontière avec la russie mais si
vous voulez y avait il y avait un front
du nord qui descendait la biélorussie
directement vers kiev il y avait un
grand fond de l'est qui passait
notamment par soumis qui allait aussi en
direction de de kiev et puis il y avait
le front du sud qui est d'ailleurs le
front cas le mieux fonctionné ils ont
réussi à se séparer de toute cette bande
de terre mais là on voit bien que
l'échelle des combats c'est considérer
considérablement réduite revanche une
intensité des combats elle n'a
probablement pas diminué et par ailleurs
il faut pas oublier que les ordres de
grandeur en termes de mobilisation
restent les mêmes c'est que les russes
continuent à avoir environ 200 205 de
150 à 200 mille hommes qui sont engagés
dans cette opération ce qui encore une
fois est extrêmement faible pour
l'invasion d'un pays plus grand que la
france est de 40 millions d'habitants
olfa qui nous saluent on voit peut-être
repartir dans le donbass pour voir un
peu cette carte donc on se rappelle ce
l'audience car mme ashton
à cette taille et on voit aussi que la
partie hachuré donc qu'ils étaient les
les anciennes positions évidemment de ce
côté là ils n'ont pas énormément avancé
non plus 6 par rapport aux taux
territoire séparatiste ses aveux oui ils
ont peu avancé pour les pour les raisons
qu'on ai dit tout à l'heure et encore
une fois c'est une avancée qui est lente
c'est ce qui fait qu'aujourd'hui on peut
se demander donc qu'elles sont dans quel
état sont les forces russes et donc
après lé 2 ap déjà à presevo donnait ce
qu'il y ait des chances jusqu'où
pourront elles allaient dans le bon bah
c'est combien de temps leur faudra-t-il
et puis après une école à la fin
éventuelle de la bataille du dombass est
ce que les russes auront les moyens
d'aller d'aller au delà sachant qu'il ya
deux grandes possibilités c'est soit de
filer au nord
vers kharkiv soin de lancer une
offensive au sud après carson sachant
que là il ya aussi l'hypothèse
l'ukrainienne faut pas non plus oublier
la possibilité d'une contre-offensive de
contre 26 l'ukrainienne même si les
contre attaques ukrainienne qu'on a vu
depuis ces dernières semaines pour
l'instant elles ont fait plus ou moins
long feu alors justement c'est que c'est
contre offensive ou est ce qu'elle se
situe pour l'instant et qu'est ce
qu'elles ont à apporter
c'est très simple mais il y en a deux
principales
l'une qui est tout au nord du dispositif
russe autour de la ville de kharkiv
alors kharkiv c'est la deuxième ville
d'ukraine c'est 1,5 million d'habitants
les russes avaient essayé pendant l'acte
1 de la guerre d'encercler la ville
n'étaient pas parvenus
et donc les en fait il avait donc les
ukrainiens depuis en deux - ont repris
pas mal de territoire c'est tout le
territoire qui est inquiétant bleus
voilà elle en fait les les rues de se
sont aussi repliées
ça ça semble donc donc cibler les
ukrainiens n'ont pas
battu littéralement de plein d'unités
russe cessé il ya eu une avancée
ukrainienne et pirus mais on peut penser
que la la stratégie ukrainienne c'était
un peu une manoeuvre développement des
russes pour mettre en difficulté leur
lignes logistiques qui allait vers le
fer le pearl daumas et l'ail les
ukrainiens ont raté si elle que la
contre attaque n'a pas réussi à aller en
profondeur d'un dispositif bruce elle
s'est arrêtée on voyait une petite
rivière basse et toujours le devenir des
tailleurs
qui courent à l'est de kharkiv en fait
ils n'ont pas vraiment réussi à franchir
la l'autre rive pour passer à l'est et
pour vraiment mettre en danger le
dispositif vous donc non seulement à
kharkiv la contre attaque ukrainienne
s'est arrêté mais depuis deux semaines
on assiste à un mouvement inverse
d'accéder de nouveau les russes qui met
la pression sur les ukrainiens dans
cette région alors ils ont pris un
certain nombre de reprises certain
nombre de villages de petites localités
pour l'instant c'est pas très symbolique
mais il ya visiblement un changement de
dynamique sur ce front et on peut se
demander quels sont les objectifs du
russe à court moyen terme ya eu beaucoup
de débats parmi les experts est ce que
c'est juste pour pour fixer des troupes
ukrainienne autour de kharkiv pour qui
on est moins dans le nom basse pour que
la danse est heureuse de l'ambassade
plus vite ou est-ce que cet indic
quelque chose d'un futur nouvel
objective russe
après le nom basse je pense que
clairement il est trop tôt pour le pour
le dire mais c'est clairement un endroit
qu'il faut suivre l'autre contre attaque
elle est dans le sud de l'ukraine
au dessus de la ville de carson à leur
personne c'est une ville qui à
l'embouchure du n'ya plus nyamsi le
grand fleuve qui traverse de noir reçu
de l'ukraine est en fait personne c'est
une tête de pont c'est la seule tête de
pont russe pour franchir le de gamme
donc déjà c'est assez stratégique pour
les russes et puis on voit que la
distance entre personnes et la crimée
les extrêmement faible veut pas dire de
bêtises mais ne veut y avoir à peu près
100 km donc pour les ukrainiens lancé
une contre-offensive à cet endroit là ça
peut rapidement avoir une portée
stratégique donc ça on en parle depuis
maintenant
plus de deux mois pour l'instant les
ukrainiens n'ont pas été capables comme
à à kharkiv réellement de mettre en
danger les russes dans la profondeur ils
ont établi une tête de pont parce que là
aussi sur les lignes de front il ya de
nouveau une rivière qui a living in
houlette ils ont réussi à la franchir
établir une tête de pont mais il
n'arrive pas à aller au delà et là on en
arrive aux problèmes ukrainien c'est que
les russes malgré tout ont cet avantage
quantitatif en termes d'artillerie ils
ont aussi une supériorité aérienne qui
n'est pas totale mais qui est tout à
fait réelle ils ont notamment des avions
d'attaqué au sol qui sont de
littéralement des camions à bomber et
donc les ukrainiens qui ont une
une artillerie assez agile et
extrêmement précises notamment avec les
nouvelles armes occidentales en revanche
tout simplement il manque de muscles
pour aller pour aller au delà et donc
qu'ils peuvent mettre en difficulté
localement les russes mais il n'arrive
pas à avancer pour ça il faudrait plus
de plus de masse or on sait aujourd'hui
que les ukrainiens ont perdu énormément
d'hommes dans le nom basse même les
officiels ukrainiens l'ont dit on a
parlé un moment ça les estimations sont
montés jusqu'à 500 morts par jour
jusqu'à 1000 perte perte au sens général
c'est à me laisser capturer morts 1000
par jour c'est absolument considérable
c'est qu'on arrive quasiment une brigade
chaque semaine et puis par ailleurs
quelles étaient les troupes qui était
dans le donbass est ce que dans le
donbass n'avait pas été envoyée les les
meilleures troupes celles qui avaient le
plus d'expérience et les nouveaux
conscrits qui arrive parce que parce que
là l'ukraine a sonné la mobilisation
générale
quelle est leur valeur militaire est ce
qu'il ya suffisamment de sous-officiers
d'officier pour assurer leur essai là on
a un vrai doute sur la capacité
l'ukrainienne a lancé une véritable
contre offensive avec une portée
stratégique
surtout qu' il faut pas oublier enfin de
toujours désert occidental il va à
l'ukraine c'est vrai mais face à la
france par exemple a livré je crois qu
on est à 12 quel nom césar de 155 mm qui
sont qui sont d'excellents d'armes mais
en face il ya 2500 pièces d'artillerie
russe est en réalité la majorité de
l'armement ukrainiens s'étaient de
l'armement soviétique or cet armement
c'est betty qui représente la grande
masse des armes du chrétienne
aujourd'hui c'est qu'ils ont des gros
problèmes de ravitaillement terme de
munitions parce que c'est des munitions
spécifiques il ya toujours cet exemple
en union soviétique c'est d'un calibre
de 150 2 mm dans les pays occidentaux
ses 155 mm donc vous pouvez pas
interchanger les les les munitions et
donc aujourd'hui les ukrainiens non
seulement ils sont à court de munitions
mais maintenant ils doivent changer de
système d'armes passés à des systèmes
occidentaux et ça c'est une gageure donc
ce thème de l'offensive d'été c'est une
possibilité il ya franchement aucune
garantie effectivement on a une
obligation d'ordre hasna qui dit on dit
kiev en france est peut-être qu'on peut
faire une petite aparté sur sa sur la
sur le soir sans bruit ses talents nous
au figaro on utilise les noms de villes
en ukrainien par exemple on dit kharkiv
nip à kharkov on le dit nicolas l'ifp à
nikolaïev comme disent les russes selon
ledit le vif fait pas le veuf enfin et
cetera et cetera ont fait une exception
pour kiev et on ne dit pas qu'ils font
on dit qu'il ya violence l'ancien
écriture russe
voilà c'est une convention c'est pas
forcément extrêmement logique sur le
fond mais ça a le mérite enfin que tout
le monde
voilà donc c'est
mais aujourd'hui dans la majorité de la
presse on utilise les noms une autre
manière je vois que les temples les
russes disent vladimir zelensky 10 paulo
d'immigrés lenski
on a eu on a pas une personne aussi
personne c'est quand même une ville qui
a été récupéré par les russes est ce
qu'on s'est un peu comment ça se passe
sur place parce que c'est comme une
ville très important des oui je vous
conseille un article
qu'on a écrit il ya une semaine ou deux
maintenant sur le le contrôle russe qui
s'opère dans toute cette partie sud de
la russie et qui va qui va si loin c'est
à dire que par exemple le rouble
aujourd'hui est clairement la monnaie
utilisée par là par les habitants ils
reprennent en main l'école pour ossifié
les programmes aussi fier la langue
et puis par ailleurs il ya des
administrations qui sont à la fois
civile et militaire qui se met en place
avec des habitants pro-russe de là-bas
évidemment je chapeaute et on l'a encore
vu hier avec un responsable je crois
d'ailleurs peut-être que c'est à carson
mais j'ai un doute
nouveau responsable local qualité russe
et qui est un ancien du du fsb donc on
voit très bien que là il ya une logique
de
contrôle de ces territoires alors
certains historiens par le monde
colonisation puisqu'en fait ces
territoires ont longtemps été russe à
partir de la fin du xviiie mais c'était
un mouvement de colonisation puisque
tout le sud de l'ukraine historiquement
il appartenait plutôt à l' empire
ottoman et donc il ya eu des
colonisation de peuplement russes qui
sont arrivés tout au long du 19ème et
une politique de colonisation donc les
ukrainiens aujourd'hui auront tendance à
parler de recolonisation mais en tout
cas ça c'est un mouvement politique très
puissant et qui laisse penser que si les
russes arrivent continue à tenir ces
territoires militairement tout indique
qu'ils veulent les contrôler ils l'ont
dit d'ailleurs définitivement et donc
probablement ou peut-être les intégrer à
la fédération de russie alors sous
quelle forme par quel biais ce qu'il y
aura un référendum c'est pas encore ça
dépendra aussi du cours de la guerre
alors juste avant je vous montrais
l'article dont vous parlez alexis qui va
s'afficher ici attendait le temps que je
grandisse il frappe la balle à carson
les ukrainiens vivre le cauchemar
éveillé de l'occupation russe le
résident et spécial parti de margaux ben
que vous pouvez retrouver sur le site du
figaro que vont vous encourage à lire
article très intéressant effectivement
on a l efi qui nous dit on sait qu'il
est environ cent trente mille soldats
écrire est-ce que c'est effectivement
combien il y en a deux combien de
soldats quels rapports de force des de
chaque côté à l'autre je suis pas sûr
que donner un chiffre soit
vaudra grand chelem c'est que valent ces
soldats c'est encore une fois on peut
pas comparer
un soldat kkk 35 ans d'expérience
militaire ce qui s'est déjà battu dans
le donbass en 2014 et un soldat qui
vient d'arriver qui n'a pas été formés
ou formés en quelques semaines il ya là
il ya la question de l'équipement il ya
quand même énormément de témoignages de
soldats ukrainien qui disent qu'ils sont
envoyés sur le front quasiment sans
équipement et là on parle pas d'armes
lourdes dont on parle de casque gilet
pare balle de
2-2 de fusils d'assaut de etc donc il ya
un vrai souci à l'endos du coup les
l'ordre de grandeur est compliqué à dire
mais mais mais disons qu'en nombre
d'hommes il ya probablement pas moins de
soldats ukrainien que de soldats russes
on en ukraine voire peut-être plus
d'ukrainiens et surtout il ya un
réservoir d'hommes qui est bien plus
grand en ukraine qu'en russie puisque la
russie n'a pas sonné la mobilisation
générale auxquelles elle s'appuie si on
est celle d'un professionnel kremlin a
encore redit hier ils ne veulent pas
employer de conscrits ou de réserviste
en ukraine alors ils dealent vie
justement ils sont en train de
s'entraîner est ce qu'ils peuvent faire
la différence au début de l'automne ce
qui sont pas forcément déjà sur le front
mais qui sont en cours d'entraînement
est ce que c'est une stratégie à long
terme c'est une inconnue mais mais le
problème c'est que ça dépendra tellement
du cours de la guerre cet été et ce
qu'on assistera à un effondrement des
trucs des troupes ukrainienne dans le
combat on peut pas encore le savoir on a
vu un effondrement extrêmement localisé
dans la région de ses murs de neige les
échéances mais est ce que l'on peut
déduire de sa un effondrement plus large
dans tout le dombass aujourd'hui on peut
pas le dire parce que notamment ne
connaît pas l'état des forces russes et
on connaît très mal aussi l'état des
forces iraniennes
et puis qu'est ce qui va se passer
personne on ne peut pas mais en tout cas
c'est la stratégie une chrétienne en à
bergues où kimono critique c'est alors
c'est moi qui ait titré le lève comme ça
qui me dit que les russes n'ont jamais
perdu l'avantagent
c est ce qu on peut vraiment affirmer ça
parce que non il ya il ya eu il ya eu un
échec greuze dans le dans le nord du
pays c'est à l'eau mais mais mais la
russie l'a quasiment inconnu d'une telle
réorientation delà de la guerre signifie
que leurs acteurs n'avaient pas
fonctionné il était en fait pris
dans une impasse et va-t-il encerclé
tout un tas de grandes villes
ukrainiennes sans pouvoir les prendre
avec des routes de ravitaillement une
logistique était extrêmement vulnérables
et on sait que ces grandes batailles
robben ces batailles de sièges et un
avantage aux défenseurs c'était une
guerre d'attrition d'usure qu'elle ait
tourné au désavantage de la de la russie
donc ce qu'ils ont fait de rêve de
changer de leurs braqué avec l'acte 2
qu'est la grande bataille du donbass
c'était probablement une bonne idée
militaire mais ça voulait bien dire que
l'acteur s'est pas mal passé il n'y a
pas de doute là dessus effectivement on
a parlé de ça excusez moi je sais c'est
dur elle est fille qui vous remercie
pour votre réponse merci à vous et
n'hésitez pas à continuer à poser vos
questions on est encore ensemble pendant
pendant quelques temps on peut peut-être
parler du contrôle de la mer a contraint
de la mer qui est très important dans
cette guerre et surtout papa d'une
petite île qui s'appelle l'île aux
serpents et malheureusement je crois que
cette si on va pouvoir la voir ici sur
cette carte alors je vais devoir décaler
la carte que vous ne la voyez pas jusque
là hop elle est ici donc complètement à
gauche là ici le serpent qui est très
loin finalement de sébastopol qui assez
loin enfin qu' à ses proches de le
craindre mais loin des des jeux pas dire
des bêtises doit y avoir 300 km entre
l'île de l'île aux serpents ou les
serpents et sébastopol est à peu près
100 km entre ses désirs de grandeur
entre lille et le serpent et odessa et
en fait ce qu'on voit mal c'est quand
même en jeu si le serpent est à 30 40 km
de la côte ukrainienne
vraiment à à l'ouest alors être ça
redescend puis après c'est là c'est la
roumanie est donc en mettre cette île de
france yves le 24 février on se souvient
de cet enregistrement qui s'était
avérée
il était fou en tout cas les conclusions
ont été tirées et était erroné c'étaient
les ukrainiens qui aurait refusé de se
rendre et et qui serait mort en
héroïquement au combat sur l'île aux
serpents avant que le croiseur moskva
tir avec ses canons de 130 mm sur le sur
l'île et ratiboise tout en réalité c'est
pas comme ça que ça s'est passé les
soldats ukrainien qui était sur l'île se
sont rendus ont été faits prisonniers
par les russes y ont envoyé à sébastopol
mais bref les russes contrôlées l'île
aux serpents depuis le 24 février
il y avait installé de plus en plus de
force notamment des systèmes
antimissiles des systèmes de batteries
côtières et sauf que c'est devenu
véritablement un symbole surtout quand
le croiseur meuse ou bas a été coulé le
14 avril très probablement par deux
missiles antinavires une craignent un
neptune rappelé que ce que représente un
peu se croisèrent regardons c'est le
navire amiral c'était le navire amiral
de la flotte de la mer noire alors
c'était un très vieux bateau de 1982 qui
avait jamais été modernisé et qu'ils
avaient probablement pas une utilité
militaire considérable mais ça a été un
choc un choc pour les uns mais c'est un
énorme bateau des plus grands bateaux
bateau russe en plus ces pays s'appelle
moscou fameux soulas et moscou donc ça
me luc immense effort et en plus il a
été cité pas de bêtises fabriqué en
ukraine mais bon en tout cas ça a été un
choc pour les russes qui en fait se sont
rendus compte qu'il y avait une menace
navale ukrainienne alors même qu'ils
avaient détruit la marine ukrainienne
qui était en réalité inexistante c'est
un ensemble de petits patrouille et un
petit peu en fait mémé de cette menace
ukrainienne elle vient d des batteries
de missiles anti navires ce terrestre
sur les côtes une chrétienne et qui en
fait d'écrire un rayon d'action de son
100 200 voire 300 kilomètres donc pas
très loin de sébastopol et qui font que
les russes qui ont la flotte la plus
puissante de la mer noire qui n'est pas
énorme mais quand même été un peu
modernisé et bien ils se rendent compte
qu'ils ont une capacité de
d'action dans le nord de la mer noire
back in et qu'il n'est pas du tout total
et donc les ukrainiens ont
terminé tu es on dise d'une capacité
déni d'accès une sorte de guérilla
navale techno navale c'est que si si ils
mettent des des navires dans cette zone
ils seront détruits par l'ukraine
détruits avait aucune garantie mais il
ya mais il ya un risque et donc quand
même des navires modernes qui sont
capables de faire face à cette menace au
sommeil en interne anti aériens menés
que 3 ces trois frégates grigorovitch
bon ils ont ils en ont trois dont une
qui est bloqué en méditerranée parce que
le détroit de du bosphore et et fermez
donc ils ont deux bateaux ou non un qui
a repris le grade de navire amiral ils
en ont deux si la la la la la guerre
dure des mois je pense qu'ils n'ont
aucune envie de prendre le risque de
perdre leurs deux derniers bateaux un
peu un peu me donne un peu gros delà de
la flotte de la mer noire et donc vont
être les russes se sont tout simplement
retiré progressivement delà du nord de
la mer noire ce qui ne les empêche pas
de faire des frappes de missiles depuis
des navires
vers la terre ukrainienne samedi arrive
très bien parce que la portée des
missiles calibre ses 2500 km dont ils
n'ont pas besoin de se mettre au large
dose et ça donc ça ça ne les dérange pas
en revanche ce que ça implique mais
toute manière ça on le savait c'est que
c'est qu'une opération
russe vers l'ouest de l'ukraine pour
prendre le port d'odessa et finalement
priver l'ukraine d'un accès à la mer
aujourd'hui c'est pas possible toute
manière une offensive pas leur mère
était impossible sans une opération
terrestre or comme l'opération terrestre
et nenê n'a plus cours depuis
depuis maintenant deux mois avec les
russes en position défensive à carson
ça ne change pas ça ne bouleverse pas la
donne militairement pour les russes
simplement ils prennent conscience d'une
vulnérabilité qui n'avait probablement
pas imaginer
avant la guerre est juste pour terminer
sur l'île aux serpents il ya cette
menace des missiles il ya la menace des
drones et aiderait deux turcs qui n'ont
pas cessé de pilonner l'île alors les
russes se sont défendus ils ont
probablement abattu des des drones et
malgré tout c'est une sorte de guerre
d'usure de guerre d'attrition qui n'a
aucun intérêt militaire pour les russes
et là maintenant il ya les canons dans
son enquête multi donc la retirerais
allons porter américaine les y mars qui
sont arrivés en ukraine 80 km ils
peuvent frapper l'île aux serpents et
donc là le les russes se sont dit on va
pas tenir coi social de tenir une île du
nil au 17 hectares qui nous sert pas sur
le moment à grand chose et se prendre
des tirs de canon sur la figure et donc
ils se sont retirés mais c'est pas pour
autant que les ukrainiens pourront
reprendre l'île aux serpents même s'ils
ont planté un drapeau ne vont pas
l'occuper parce qu'ils auront le même
problème les russes s'adressant plus
grave ils pourront pas l'occuper les
russes tireront et ils seront pas
capables de défendre cette vidéo on
apparaître d'un appât est ce que
justement il se retire pour aussi de
dire aux ukrainiens revenait après il
peut il peuvent leur tirer dessus assez
facile moi aussi je pense que le plus
probable c'est plutôt le statu quo
c'est-à-dire aura personne sur cet îlot
pastoraux dangereux occupe et en tant
que le louer l'ouest de l'ukraine ne
sera pas un enjeu militaire aujourd'hui
c'est un enjeu militaire qui est
suspendu alors beaucoup de questions
très intéressantes razana qui me dit
qu'on est bientôt à me lever va écouter
partager ce live ainsi s'il vous plaît
on atteindra bientôt les millions des à
960 actuellement il narre qui me dit les
rues sont ils pour projet justement
d'attaqué au dessin alors c'était un
objectif de base
ça ressemble beaucoup et ça ferait sens
d'ailleurs un peu de vue stratégique et
militaire étant donné la politique est
là elle est la vision russe
justement pour pour contrôler la mer
noire et pour priver l'ukraine un accès
à la mer il est quasi certain que c'est
un objectif de guerre probablement qui
trottent dans la dans la tête des
dirigeants qui sont proches du kremlin
mais faut distinguer les buts de guerre
hier dans l'absolu qu'est ce que vous
voudriez est par ailleurs qu'est ce
qu'on peut faire étant donné le rapport
de forces militaires sur le terrain or
aujourd'hui on l'a dit les combats sont
dans le donbass les russes n'ont pas les
moyens avec deux cent mille hommes de
mener une autre opération vers l'ouest
de l'ukraine ça n'est pas possible ça
n'est pas d'actualité donc c'est une
question qu'il faut bien le dire c'est
une question qui pourra se poser quand
en réalité pour peut-être et s'est même
pas sûrs dont deux mois trois mois
quatre mois ça voyez c'est pas une
problématique de court terme
justement on avait quelques questions
sur ça et il faut rappeler aussi qu'il
avait que le cul cul que la transnistrie
c'est un territoire occupé par des
contrôles est en tout cas oui elle en
fait ça c'est pour le coup ça appartient
la moldavie est simplement en 1991 comme
la moldavie après après son indépendance
il ya cette bande de terre extrêmement
fine qui dès 1991 cessé de facto séparée
la moldavie même si officiellement elle
en fait partie c'est la transnistrie et
donc c'est des séparatistes pro-russes
et donc depuis 91 il ya quelques
centaines jusqu'à 2000 soldats russes
qui sont là mais c'est une sorte de
statu quo de conflit larvé non résolus
évidemment si les russes arrivés à
reconstituer ce qu'on appelait autant de
l'opirus la nouveau raciale à la
nouvelle russie sert tout le sud de la
russie tous ces territoires qui avait
été repris sur l' empire ottoman et bien
effectivement on aurait une bande de
terre qu'ils iraient jusqu'à la
transnistrie qui du coup tu on peut il
même air mais concrètement ça voudrait
dire si les russes revendiquer la
transnistrie que le conflit s'étendrait
non plus seulement à l'ukraine mais
aussi à la moldavie mais là encore il
faut bien garder à l'esprit que ça ce
sont des objectifs qu'on ne peut
envisager que non que dans quel lieu
dans plusieurs mois
on à l effet qu il repose une question
en disant qu'ils avaient peut-être pas
partie du sujet mais comment expliquer
le soutien de certains pays par exemple
d'afrique ou d'asie à la russie il ya il
ya plusieurs raisons il ya déjà jeu ça
c'est une leçon de la guerre en ukraine
depuis le 24 février c'est que on parle
souvent on en occident la communauté
internationale ont invité la communauté
à ce qu'on appelle la communauté
internationale c'est souvent la
communauté occidentale
si vous regardez les les pays qui ont
voté les résolutions
condamnant est d'ailleurs la première
résolution s'était même pas le verbe
condamné c'est un verbe plus faible
quantité déploré
l'invasion russe de l'ukraine
il y avait plus d'un tiers j'épluche et
fantasmer plus d'un tiers des états de
la planète qui s'étaient abstenus et est
en réalité c'est le seul tiers d'état de
la planète représente est largement plus
la moitié de la population mondiale et
si maintenant on regarde de manière plus
significative les pays qui appliquent
des sanctions contre la russie c'est
c'est assez frappant c'est une guerre
c'est une carte de la guerre froide
c'est la communauté occidentale c'est
l'europe les états unis
le japon un petit peu la corée du sud
voilà c'est tout et donc tous les autres
pays regardent aussi cette guerre en
disant mais attendez ça n'est pas notre
guerre donc réglé peu après il ya des
enjeux économiques économique
l'afrique des tombes beaucoup de
certaines exportations russes
ukrainiennes notamment en termes
alimentaires et donc il est clair que là
que la russie a des idées à des moyens
de pression qui sont réelles et puis
aussi une raison plus politique plus
idéologique y avait un article
intéressant de la revue du grand
continent sur ce sujet
on pourrait se dire les états africains
quand même ont vécu la colonisation sont
aujourd'hui extrêmement attachés à la
souveraineté alors rien alors il ya un
état qui agressent à notre état ne
respecte pas des frontières
territoriales pourquoi donc
c'est étonnant pourquoi il ne condamne
pas et sauf qu'il ya plein de
raisonnement on va dire
héritées du colonialisme qui se greffent
là dessus par exemple en disant mais
attendez les frontières de l'ukraine ce
sont des frontières coloniales puisque
ce sont des frontières qui ont été
imposées
ce qui est inexact et et staline qui a
décidé des frontières actuelles de
l'ukraine mais mais mais mais voilà
c'est une sorte de ce sont des
frontières illégitime comme en afrique
et donc tout in se bat contre
l'impérialisme américain il ya des toute
cette rhétorique anti-impérialiste
quelques traits en cours en afrique en
asie dans une partie de l'asie et c'est
alors on harnais ce qui nous dit qu est
ce qu elle qui justifie la résidence des
ukrainiens alors qu'elles savent qu'ils
ne tiendront pas cette résistance n'est
t'elle pas absurde on peut rappeler que
le rapport de forces sur le terrain mais
on ne voit rien on sait pas s'il médias
n'ont pas
encore une fois on est on est dans une
guerre d'attrition alors là dans le
donbass les ukrainiens et fait le pari
que cette guerre d'attrition il voulait
défendre de l'avant c'est à dire
vraiment tenir le plus longtemps
possible et que les russes perdent le
plus de pertes le plus d'hommes peu
fatigués et on voit quelle est la
stratégie ukrainienne dans le donbass
elle a échoué c'est-à-dire que
visiblement les russes ont réussi à
avancer et grâce à leur artillerie les
ukrainiens ont perdu beaucoup plus
d'hommes que les russes dans le donbass
mais en revanche à l'échelle de de
l'ukraine tout entière cette guerre
d'usure on sait pas on sait aujourd'hui
qu'il ya des problèmes de munitions pour
les pour les ukrainiens ça c'est une
réalité ils l'ont dit mais il y aura
aussi peut-être des problèmes de
munitions chez les russes par exemple en
termes de son appel dmd des munitions
complexe et les missiles de de
précisions les russes ont tiré
dernière destination qui était il ya
déjà une semaine ou deux c'était plus de
2600 on est peut-être autour des 3000
c'est plus que les stocks qui était
imaginé avant le conflit et ils tirent
des missiles de plus en plus anciens
parfois des missiles antinavires sur des
cibles terrestres qui veut dire qu'ils
sont aux tensions de dons et par
ailleurs il ya la question de logistique
les armes lourdes
occidentales qui sont livré à l'ukraine
et ne sont pas nombreuses donc elles
peuvent pas renverser la donne
militairement sur le terrain mais en
revanche comme elles sont très précises
et aujourd'hui à longue portée avec les
mrc américain ils peuvent cibler les
dépôts de munitions en arrière du front
très en profondeur dans le dispositif
russe ils elles peuvent frapper avec un
mot renseignements les centres de
commandement et l'oeil et là on va dire
que des quelques frappes peuvent faire
très mal russe parce que parce que la
logistique russe est un point faible
qu'on avait eu comme on avait vu pendant
l'acte 1 la logistique bruxelles passe
par les rails
donc les objets arrivent par le pape par
le train puis ça va demander dans des
camions et ça va sur le front
mais mais si les routes sont obligés de
repousser leurs dépôts d'armement parce
qu'ils sont menacés par les
par l'effort et le par les frappes du
crânienne c'est à dire qu'il y aura
moins de trains et plus de camions et
plus on met moins de munitions dans les
camions ça va moins vite et c'est donc à
tous ces enjeux-là qui fait que très
franchement on ne connaît pas l'issue de
cette guerre est une guerre c'est par
principe dans une bière il faut faut pas
dire enfin participe à la fin on ne sait
pas on ne sait pas ce qu'il peut se
passer effectivement est-ce qu'on peut
néanmoins
essayer de savoir quelle est la
stratégie russe on n'a jamais réussit
très bien à quoi tu as à savoir on avait
quelques idées au début de la guerre
c'est sûrement des quelques idées mais
aujourd'hui est ce qu'on s'est un peu
calé quel est le but de la russie
actuelle alors c'est intéressant parce
que
le président du conseil de sécurité
russe dont j'oublie le nom il ça va
revenir a récemment enfin hier mais
mardi les objectifs stratégiques de la
russie et si les mêmes qu'au premier
jour alors c'est la démilitarisation de
craine la dénazification
la protection des populations du donbass
et puis par ailleurs le fait que
l'ukraine soit neutre
enfin neutraliser la neutralisation mais
c'est pas la destruction de ces
puissances neutre qui ne fasse pas
partie de l'otan et voilà qu'il ya une
sorte de d'état tampon d'inconnus
diplomatiques entre les
donc ça c'est ça peut voler lundi
démilitarisation il faut imaginer ça
peut vouloir dire beaucoup de choses ça
peut vouloir dire une destruction
complète de l'armée ukrainienne
neutralisation
[Musique]
qu'est ce que ça veut dire quelles
garanties etc dénazification est-ce que
la destruction d'azov du bataillon
oiseaux à marioupol est-ce que c'est
suffisant pour les russes en réalité on
ne on ne sait pas ce qui est très claire
aujourd'hui c'est qu'il ya des objectifs
territoriaux russe qui vont très
probablement au delà du dombass
jusqu'où on ne sait pas et je ne suis
pas sûr que les russes eux-mêmes le
savent le sache exactement parce que ça
dépend aussi de la situation militaire
sur le terrain oui du coup avec lille -
justement est-ce que la russie peut
conquérir la moitié du pays l'ukraine
c'est assez clair un très vaste
territoire très vaste le terrifiant aval
que là il ya 20% du tireur c'est 20 %
donc faudrait prendre un tiers
supplémentaires mais sachant que tout
n'est pas n'est pas proportionnel il est
passé de 20 à 30
parce que par exemple si l'armée
ukrainienne dont le nom basse
s'effondre brutalement
après le reste les très vite c'est aussi
là dessus que conques et russie se
disait rigueur notre objectif c'est de
détruire notre premier objectif c'est
détruire la même craignait si on peut la
détruire proche de nous de nos
frontières c'est plus simple et après le
reste ira plus vite mais ça c'est ce que
veut le lyrisme est ce que c'est ce qui
arrivera on ne le sait pas je remercie
paul marcellin qui nous parle de nikolai
patrushev absolument c'est le cas ici
merci paul sams ryan demande pour
bonjour la russie peut-elle montrer une
nouvelle sorte de missiles pendant la
guerre en ukraine que l'on n'a pas
encore vu j'ai pas si par la musique
alors
déjà première chose il faut arrêter avec
les armes magiques ça ça n'existe pas où
ça n'a pas
ça peut pas renverser le cours d'une
guerre il ya eu plein d'histoires la
scie pendant la seconde guerre mondiale
sur les super arme de d'hitler
voilà parle armes nucléaires qui ont 45
a eu peut-être un héros et on recommence
à accélérer bref il n'ya pas d'armes
magique donc ça c'est la première chose
tous les experts militaires le dise le
répète une arme ça s'intègre dans un
environnement et système dans son
ensemble qui est plus ou moins
performant première chose deuxième chose
il ya une arme nouvelle qui a été
employée par les russes
c'était un
missile hyper sonic
voilà quel était le kindle qui a été
tirée par des avions dans le nord
l'ouest de l'ukraine mais ça c'était
plus d'avoir une frappe de prestige et
puis aussi un message on va dire envoyer
aux excédents tôt le l'utilisation de ce
missile en soi était absolument inutile
il aurait pu enterrer leur domicile sont
été la même chose mais ça envoyé un
message dans le cadre de la du rapport
de force de la dissuasion nucléaire
etc etc
on a pas mal de questions aussi sur les
sur les négociations razida parlant qui
me dit distinguer des objectifs
politiques et militaires plus ils ont la
main militairement plus en gourmands
politiquement c'est sûr pour l'instant
les négociations il n'y en a pas
vraiment en tout cas pas que pape a
adressé - officiel qu'au début du
conflit je passais vous souvenez mais il
y avait des représentants des deux pays
aient l'envié locales et en biélorussie
pas très loin de la frontière entre la
biélorussie et l'ukraine ça s'est
littéralement arrêté je sais pas si vous
vous souvenez mais mais après les
massacres de boudhha ça creuse de butch
à l'ouest de de kiev et puis par
ailleurs il ya toute cette période où de
manière générale les ukrainiens étaient
beaucoup plus
optimiste et dans les discours il y
avait un discours de reconquête c'est le
seul scénario qui serait acceptable ça
serait le scénario de retour ek santé
mais avant 2014 c'est à dire on reprend
la craie mais tous le nom basse etc
ce moment d'euphorie qui correspondait
au moment où on se disait mais les
russes sont en déroute quand même
aujourd'hui on en est plus là et très
clairement même si le soutien occidental
est totale et elles mêmes par les
manuels macron cas souvent souhaité un
discours avec poutine a même rappelé que
la france souhaitait une victoire totale
de l'ukraine néanmoins même des
représentants de l'otan comme le son
secrétaire général ont dit il appartient
à l'ukraine de dire jusqu'où elle veut
aller et est ce qu'elle est prête à
faire des sépales autant de le décider
c'est à l'ukraine de décider mais ils
ont quand même mis sur la table
officiellement le sujet des négociations
et des concessions territoriales donc ça
veut dire qu'aujourd'hui il ya deux
nouveaux on commence à reparler de
nouveau de possibles négociations
ça veut dire quelque chose militairement
serre que les ukrainiens
on en finit avec le discours qui était
vraiment pas très réaliste
d'effondrement de l'armée russe et
inversement on voit que les victoires
local de la russie ne présage pas
forcément d'une capacité d'action qui
permettront aux russes d'avancé pour
prendre la moitié du pays sans s'arrêter
et donc dès lors il ya ce qu'on appelle
un point d'équilibré ou un
centre de gravité qui commença à se
dessiner clausewitz appelait ça un point
culminant et à partir du moment où les
deux belligérants commence à imaginer un
tel point bas ils ont qu'il commence à
se dire qu'il pourrait qu'il pourrait
négocier alors qu'aujourd'hui on en est
là oui mais alors en même temps vu que
les russes pour tuer d'avancé dans le
ton basse c'est pour ça qu'on a c'est un
début cirque on recommence à parler de
l'hypothèse de négociations on n'est pas
du tout dans le dur aujourd'hui des
négociations parce que les russes
continuent à avancer et que la situation
est aujourd'hui inacceptable pour les
ukrainiens on a une art qui demande la
supériorité aérienne des russes ne
semble pas un avantage décisif savez
vous pourquoi alors déjà c'est un
avantage
peut-être moins grands qu'attendu il ya
encore une aviation ukrainienne on a vu
encore ce matin des des vidéos de sukhoï
25 l'ukrainien ils ont encore des
capacités de défense antiaérienne mais
là c'est intéressant les dernières
vidéos que j'ai vu c'était du système
book donc en fait des système soviétique
c'est pas des systèmes occidentaux donc
combien de temps vont-ils des munitions
ne sais pas l'aviation russe fait quand
même je crois que les deux les données
c'est 200 300
sorties par jour c'est pas non plus
gigantesque simplement fait ils n'ont
pas une capacité
aller très loin en profondeur dans le
livre dans le dispositif enfin même en
ukraine si dans le dispositif ukrainien
dans le dispositif militaire tactique ce
terrain ils peuvent y aller en revanche
ils vont pas aller à la leaf ou
difficile non parce que parce que liant
il ya encore une capacité de nuisance
une chrétienne mais en réalité on en
revanche à l'échelle du champ de
bataille c'est vrai à l'échelle du nom
basse la supériorité aérienne russe fait
la différence c'est une des raisons
principales pour lesquelles aujourd'hui
les ukrainiens n'ont pas été en mesure
de lancer des contre-offensives
importante et qui ré en or en profondeur
dans le dispositif
on a une marque de moi aussi est-ce que
les canons caesar envoyé par la france
sont utiles actuellement aux ukrainiens
et en quoi le son bilan mais ils sont
alors ils sont extrêmement utiles parce
qu'ils sont cédés canon extrêmement
précis qui porte
très loin
je crois que c maximum 40 km après ça
dépend des de munitions et je crois
qu'on ne leur a pas fourni les munitions
les les meilleurs donc celles qui vont
le plus loin mais ils sont très précis
très agile très rapide de ce point de
vue là c'est des canons de 155 mm qui
sont meilleurs que les équivalents
heureuse de 152 km mais après c'est ce
que je disais tout à l'heure il n'ya pas
d'armement magique et on leur a livré
une dizaine de 2
canon automoteur donc ça va pas changer
la donne on note une question sur les
spoliations attire des deux sur les
civils des deux côtés parce qu'on parle
côté russe on man band but d'en parler
de cotco de coutume crédit c'est aussi
une réalité c'est une c'est une réalité
ah ouais je vous invite parce que ça
c'est vraiment une question de droit
international humanitaire aussi appelé
droit des conflits armés
on a fait hier un article vraiment de
droit sur qu'est ce qu'on a fait ce
qu'on a le droit de bombarder des
bâtiments civils dans une vieille et en
fait c'est le droit le droit
international et est très riche en la
matière et donc nous on n'a absolument
pas le droit de tirer sur des bâtiments
civils de manière
indiscriminée
non proportionnée et en fait on ne peut
on a le droit de viser que dès qu'on
appelle des biens qui sont des objectifs
militaires pas des biens qui sont de
caractère civil est donc pour ça pour
qu'un bien soit un objectif militaire il
faut qu'ils aient qu'il représente un
avantage
pour le belligérant qui l'occupé et par
ailleurs il faut que la destruction de
ce bien on traîne un
avantage pour pour celui qui tire
et donc dans ce cadre là c'est là où
c'est subtil c'est que par exemple un
hôpital peut devenir un bien militaire
sais pas combien
il ya un état major qui l'occupent pour
se cacher et le fait de tirer sur un
hôpital qui est un bien civils est un
crime de guerre mais le fait de se
cacher dans un hôpital est aussi un
crime de guerre alors dû le problème
c'est qu'il ya des accusations russes et
ukrainiennes des deux côtés les russes
visiblement en parlant des dépôts
d'armes qui n'hésite pas à cacher depuis
au près de bâtiments civils mais on a
aussi vu beaucoup de vidéos de trop plu
crânienne par exemple sur une vidéo que
ça ressemblait beaucoup un gymnase
scolaire quand même donc ça c'est
d'aider des arguments russes qui sont
utilisés tout le temps ses pommettes les
l'ebit les gérants ne le dit jamais
qu'il ne respecte pas on international
ils disent c'était pas un bien civile
c'était une école qui accueillait des
armes
voilà donc ça c'est une question
difficile mais ce qui est très clair
c'est que là il ya plein de crimes de
guerre puisque tout simplement la
destruction totale de ville de villes
entières
ça n'est pas conforme à ce que dit le
droit international mais par ailleurs
c'est quelque chose qu'on a vu dans
d'autres guerres
on l'a vu aussi pendant la guerre en
irak de 2003
évidemment les russes en syrie en 2015
mais mais mais également la ville de
mossoul en irak a été complètement
détruite il ya quasiment plus rien par
là la coalition internationale donc ça
c'est un des grands enjeux aujourd'hui
du droit international humanitaire alors
on a deux petites questions va bientôt
terminer slight même mais on va quand
même prendre de vote à l'implication est
ce qu'on sait par exemple citer canada
ont été détruits depuis le début de la
guerre
je pense qu officiellement ça n'est pas
le cas alors je sais que ça fait partie
des dés c'est ce qu'affirment les
séparatistes et les les russes il me
semble qu'il n'y a aucune preuve à ce
jour ni de destruction ni comme on l'a
vu de capture par les russes de deux
canons caesar qui auraient été envoyés
dans une usine d'artillerie russe on
remarquera qui russie fournit aucune
photo de ces deux canaux alors c'est en
moyenne alors qu'ils auraient ils
auraient pu s'en vanter s'il avait ou
aurait pu inventer razana qui vous
remercie pour cette intervention soit
steve hill impartial
il vous dit j'avais une autre question
est ce qu'il ya des pays amis de la
russie qui l'aident officieusement
aider comment matériellement alors il
dit puis par le matériel mans mais aussi
alors je vais tout cas il n'y a pas de
matériaux de composants de missiles
alors il est pour la jeune et l'embargo
l'europe ça s'est posé la question de la
chine la chine ne livre pas
d'équipements militaires à la à la
russie ça c'est très clair parce que la
chine est une forme de prudential
regarde ça avec
elle a pas envie de ceux de sainte de
s'ingérer dans ce conflit c'est vraiment
pas son intérêt en revanche si jean ping
l'a redit il ya une semaine ou deux
il a dit il aidera la souveraineté russe
et alors est ce qu'il fallait entendre
par là c'est notamment que qu'il aidera
probablement le régime russe en matière
de substitution aux importations sire
que ce que la russie peut pas fabriquer
elle même notamment tout ce qui est
composants électroniques effectivement
il est probable que la que la chine
prenne le relais
des équipements dont la russie est privé
à cause des sanctions ça c'est très
probable et bien voila merci à tous
merci à ina remercie hacking tout ce qui
venait de nous rejoindre vous pouvez
bien sûr retrouver ce live en replay
sera disponible juste à la fin de
celui-ci en tout cas merci d'avoir été
très nombreux à nous poser des questions
n'hésitez pas à vous abonner à notre
chaîne youtube pour recevoir des
informations dès qu'on sera en live sur
un sujet comme celui-là merci encore
alexis merci beaucoup un sens et je
remercie également le service
infographie qui est qui a été présent
qu'il a fourni ses cartes pour mieux
comprendre ce qui se passe sur la
situation vous pouvez bien sûr retrouver
tous les articles comme on en a parlé
tout à l'heure sur le site du figaro
beaucoup d'articles très intéressant sur
la situation là bas on a des envoyés
spéciaux qui sont sur place qu'il vous
raconte ce qui se passe le la suite du
programme prochain rendez vous c'est à
14h45 le discours de politique générale
de diabète bornes ça se passe à
l'assemblée nationale on parle sur de la
politique interne thibault gauthier sera
en plateau avec guillaume tabard à
partir de 14h45 et moi je vous dis à
bientôt pour de nouveaux lives sur
figaro l'est